new data released today shows the
hispanic community was hit hard during
the pandemic both personally and
financially
christian kosser has joined us live from
our channel 8 newsroom with how health
officials are reacting to this
information
well brian it's interesting information
that was released today by the pew
research center
despite the personal and financial hits
latinos are optimistic
in the future according to the report
about half of latinos say
they or someone close to them faced
health or financial hardships
during the pandemic 52 percent say a
family member or friend
was hospitalized or died from the
coronavirus 58 percent of latinos
immigrants without citizenship or
without a green card say
they or someone in their household lost
a job or wage
since february 20 of 2020 compared to 45
percent of naturalized
u.s citizen immigrants efforts to get
latinos vaccinated according to health
officials
continue to move forward we're seeing it
at
back to school clinics throughout the
valley we're seeing it at
las vegas fire stations we're seeing it
at churches
at cardenas market at la bonita market
you're seeing organizations like me
familiavota who have done an
incredible job reaching out to latinx
community
you know with with messengers and
surrogates that are trusted that know
those communities
well this group has a higher risk of
getting covet because according to the
data
many are essential workers it also adds
that 45 percent
of hispanic adults have worked jobs that
require them to work
outside the home since the pandemic
started and another interesting note
to share hispanics leaned into family
and friends during the pandemic
the majority say they helped relatives
by delivering groceries running errands
caring for children and even loaning
money to loved ones
christian casa is 8 news now